- [Gary] I think I wanna
become the nicest man on Earth.
(laughter)
I think that might be,
that's actually
where kind of, weirdly,
where I think I'm
now interested in going.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
- [Man] So, quick
fact about CCNY,
90 percent of the
students here are immigrants,
and you're speaking
to a lot of students.
We kind of wanted
to keep it exclusive
within the CCNY community.
- [Gary] The number one thing
that I'm trying
to leave here with
is to get a couple of you
to get real fucking patient.
'Cause that is the
singular advantage.
If you actually don't
give a fuck, the way I didn't,
of what people think about you,
all through your 20's,
like you just don't care,
like you literally don't,
and you just build something
for yourself, you have
a much better chance.
So many people here will
fail in their entrepreneurial
journeys because they're
worried about what people think.
That's just what it is, my man.
That's just what it is.
People are worried
about what other people think,
how many followers they have,
how good the business is doing,
what they're doing,
where they're going,
what they're wearing.
It doesn't fucking matter.
Every single person
wanted to be a rapper.
Right, it was 1994,
everybody was gonna,
and I remember thinking, wow
how are you gonna be a rapper
if you're not writing?
How are you gonna be a rapper
if you're not in the studio?
How are you gonna be a
rapper if you're not hustling?
And it's funny, the white boy
version of that now is tech.
Everybody thinks they're gonna
build Snapchat and Instagram.
And I'm like, how
are you gonna do that
when you're at Coachella?
Basically if you're
thinking about building a house,
everybody's worried about
decorating the fucking room,
and what lighting
are you gonna have?
What color is your wallpaper?
And meanwhile, the cement you
built your house on is shit.
And it's not gonna matter,
'cause the first
time it's gonna rain,
your shit's gonna fall.
Right?
And so everybody's just jumping,
everybody's so impatient.
And listen, I get it.
I look around this
room and I associate.
I don't look
exactly like everybody,
but I came from
that same kind of place
of a lot of people, right?
When you have that
chip on your shoulder,
the hardest thing
to do is patience.
- I've seen the
struggle firsthand,
- Sure.
- I had to leave my dad
'cause he wasn't
really there for me.
- Understood.
- I've seen
struggle in the face,
how do you soften the blow?
- You could dwell on that
struggle, which is very real,
or you could change
your perspective and be like,
okay, the odds of
becoming a human being are
400 trillion to one.
My favorite story of my
life is playing checkers
with the
founder of Uber, Travis.
We're at this fancy
fucking conference in Hawaii,
and we're
playing checkers, right,
'cause it's like two in
the morning or something.
And we're just playing
fucking checkers, right?
(audience laughter)
And I'm in deep shit.
Like it's over,
like he's got me,
it's like if you've ever
played checkers, I'm finished.
And so I'm like, fuck, man,
I really don't
wanna lose this match.
(audience laughter)
And so, I decide to, I think
about it for a little bit,
like over a couple moves,
and I decide to make pretend
that I made a move
that I'm upset about,
hoping that he
reacts to it quickly.
So I make this
move, and I go, "Fuck!"
And like, try to make
pretend that I need to go back,
but like my hand was up already.
So he jumps me, which
set up a triple jump for me,
and I won.
That's how
I think about your life.
(audience applause)
- I think Gary deserves like a
really big round of applause.
(audience applause and cheering)
("White Lines" by K.A.A.N.)
This is ridiculous,
this is just one muscle.
Knock you out, DRock.
This one, just
this one back here.
- Right, right.
- How are you doing?
- I'm good, I'm good.
- I'm glad you're here.
- Likewise, thanks
for even having us.
- My pleasure.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is
episode 252 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
I think you gotta make your
actions back up your ambition.
Like, my process is
very simple, which is,
I've talked a big game, I have
a lot of wants and dreams,
and my schedule today needs
to map my big fucking mouth.
Right?
Like, that's it.
And so, one thing that shocks
people when they get closer,
I remember when
Tyler first filmed,
when Justin first filmed,
Iris, when you get to film,
the biggest thing
you're gonna know is like,
wait a minute,
it's every second.
It's actually every second.
I think time is
the asset, and so,
the one thing
I would tell you is,
as you're prospecting, as
you're trying to get sales,
you've also gotta
deliver on your work.
If you got an agency, like
selling's just the beginning.
Selling's set, like,
everybody's so
focused on selling,
a lot of people starting these
small social media agencies,
just to get clients, they forget
that after you get the clients,
you gotta fucking deliver.
Keeping business is what
actually builds big businesses,
not getting new business.
- So I guess, maybe the
question today is who are you?
And who are you willing to be?
- I love that.
I appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- You guys, keep watching.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
("White Lines" by K.A.A.N.)
- Oh, show India.
(cheers)
Yeah, so this is India.
She's still here.
- Hello.
Why don't we go around.
Why don't you tell me who
you are, where you're from,
and just one or two
sentences of what you do,
and then we'll go back around
and maybe do a little Q&amp;A,
shoot the shit a little bit.
First and foremost,
thank you so much
for being a part of this.
This is something that has
been really exciting for us.
Something I hear a
lot from Vayner employers
we're at 700-plus
people is like,
"Well, it's different,
"or it's not like it was,
or this that or we used to."
And I'm like, "Yeah".
I don't know.
- [Man 2] It's just okay.
- Of course.
I'm still me.
I'm still me at 41,
I'm just different
than I was at 32, and at 26.
It's the intent in
the heart and the passion
that has to be the same,
but how it
manifests looks different.
The big thing is,
so I would tell you
the number one thing bro,
is that you and
your brother have to
have a lot of communication.
Do you feel aligned with him?
- [Man 2] Oh yeah.
- That's great.
- [Man 2] He's
probably my best friend.
He was my best
man at my wedding.
- Great, so let's start there.
You need to have
a really hardcore,
like crying-type
conversation of the blueprint of
how you guys don't let
this business break you up.
And here is how
I would attack it:
You guys need to have a
conversation around talent.
You need to agree,
which could get real
ugly so stick with me here,
on who's more
talented right now.
I promise you
you'll be able to keep
everything the way you want
if you and your
brother are aligned.
Everything stems from the top
and then it just comes down to
how much you guys care about it,
and you care
about it, obviously.
But you can't be crippled.
Everybody here is
judging themselves.
We're just
doing the best we can.
I get so sad
when somebody's like,
this place changed,
and they're
saying it in a bad way.
It breaks my heart,
but I know I'm
doing everything I can
to not make it feel worse.
Of course it's changed.
Everything's changed.
The world changes.
Everything's always changing.
Thank you, guys.
(indistinct speech)
Awesome, I'll come and see you.
I'll come and see you in
the next couple of weeks,
or you'll come here if it
works, we'll figure it out.
- [Woman] Okay.
- But I'm looking
forward to catching up.
If this wasn't a
contentious meeting,
I'd be willing to be
late, but I need to run.
Awesome. Thank you
for being sympathetic.
I'll catch up
with you soon, okay?
- [Woman] Yeah,
of course, thanks a lot.
- Thank you.
("White Lines" by K.A.A.N.)
Hey, Jeff, we're gonna
have to do this call tomorrow
just 'cause
I have to be upstairs
for Boston Consulting
talk in two minutes.
I'm just gonna hear what
Joe's gonna say right now
about what Dan wants.
I just texted him,
we're all gonna get together
but we should be in good shape.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you, man.
Thank you.
So, growing up in the liquor
business I've always learned
that it's super hard
to compete with alcohol,
so everybody back
there do your thing.
You're not hurting feelings.
People are just
not practitioners.
This room is filled with people
who have a whole lot of
things to say about stuff,
but have never actually done it.
There's a lot of opinions here
on buying Snapchat filters
in the open market place.
There's a lot of opinions here.
You feel like that?
It's true.
And I say it because
I do it in every other thing
that I don't know what
the fuck I'm talking about.
I've got opinions on everything.
But what's been fascinating
is that people got opinions
of what's actually happening
but they're not practitioners.
We have a massive
disconnect between
headline-reading and
practitionership
in the modern day of running
businesses and marketing.
And that is an enormous
arbitrage of opportunity,
and it's also the preview
to a whole lot of carnage.
And so I don't know,
I think, I, as someone who
is most comfortable in chaos,
think this is gonna be the best.
I desperately want
Wall Street to melt.
I'm so tired of all
these peace-time generals,
these CEOs that
have been navigating
the last seven
years of good times.
I think we need a massive
correction, I would prefer it.
And in that correction there
will be enormous opportunity
because the biggest
brands in the world,
overhead and infrastructure,
is based on a world
that doesn't exist anymore.
I think way too
many people here debate
and have a
romantic point of view
of how they
want the world to be.
I just react to the way
the world is actually acting.
Who am I to judge?
I was told as a kid,
playing video games
was a waste of time.
I'm watching kids making
$15 million a year play eSports.
(audience laughter)
Shit changes. Right?
And so, I think that,
I'm not sure
but what I will say is this,
the only great arbitrage
to the internet itself,
that is even out there is VR.
But as I was
talking to somebody earlier,
I believe that
consumer VR is quite far away.
To me, I react to reality.
Nobody here knows somebody
that's spending
three hours a day on VR.
Everybody here is spending seven
hours a day on their phone.
Thank you, guys.
(audience applause)
That was fun.
- That was good?
- That went well.
- Yeah.
Should I go?
Time to go?
Awesome.
I think I want to
become the nicest man on earth.
(laughter)
I think that might be,
that's actually kind of
wierdly where I think I'm now
interested in going.
("White Lines" by K.A.A.N.)
Midnight.
Just finished up
with the team, DRock.
Here you go, selfie video.
You feel better now?
- Love it.
- Thank you.
("White Lines" by K.A.A.N.)